Lauren's life is full of color
she runs an eco-friendly glitter
business and loves her work
things haven't always sparkled
her old job as an air host desk left her
tired depressed and drained
this is how she felt at her lowest
before leaving last year
it got to the point where I would do a
really long day flying and every day for
about two weeks I got home and I just
sat on my bed that exhausted I couldn't
even get out of my uniform and just sat
there crying I was making myself ill
from stress from work
she says her employers failed to support
her through difficult moments like the
death of her best friend and her mom's
cancer diagnosis making long grueling
days even harder
you know when you've lost somebody you
want to go and support your family and
be there for them but you can't do that
you need to put on a smile and a brave
face and deal with hundreds of people in
a day in a metal tube in the sky where
you've got no Escape
new figures show those feelings of
dreading a job are common
the research reveals 67 of British
employees experience anxiety about the
week ahead
the top triggers are work stress at 72
percent lack of rest and sleep also at
72 percent
and their to-do list for the week ahead
at 70 percent
they also found that 53 of people feel
anxious about working in person compared
to six percent of people if they're
anxious about working from home
statistics like those are why the who
has laid out new guidance it includes
training managers to support staff and
advice on helping people come back from
mental health related absences
if you support effectively the mental
health of your Workforce you are not
losing out on productivity losses not
losing out on where people reach a point
where they have to take absence because
they're not doing as well that's really
important and also you're retaining your
staff
it's about the finer details focusing on
how every person feels at work will make
the difference
Sky News